This is Hidden Brain, I'm Shankar Vedant. In the summer of 2022, a man named Ivan went on a vacation with two friends to Kassandra, a peninsula in Greece. During the holiday, Ivan was swimming in the ocean when a fierce riptide pulled him away from the beach. His friends alerted the Coast Guard, but he was swept out so quickly that the search operation failed to find him. For hour after hour, Ivan struggled to stay afloat. The currents carried him farther and farther from land. Eventually, he was treading water about 15 nautical miles from the beach. It was cold.
这里是《Hidden Brain》，我是尚卡尔·维丹塔姆。2022年夏天，一个名叫伊万的男子和两个朋友去希腊卡桑德拉半岛度假。假期期间，伊万在海里游泳时，一股猛烈的离岸流将他卷离了海滩。他的朋友们通知了海岸警卫队，但他被冲走得太快，搜救行动没能找到他。伊万在海里挣扎了几个小时，试图保持漂浮。水流将他带离陆地越来越远。最终，他在距离海滩约15海里处踩水。天气很冷。
Soon, it was dark. Ivan fought to keep his head above water. The night wore on. His strength began to give out. Just as he was about to drown, the first rays of the morning sun illuminated an object bobbing nearby. It was a ball. With his last ounce of strength, Ivan swam to it.
很快，天黑了。伊万努力让头露出水面。夜色渐深。他的体力开始耗尽。就在他快要溺水时，清晨的第一缕阳光照亮了附近漂浮的一个物体。那是一个球。伊万用尽最后一点力气游向它。
He clung to the partly deflated ball, and it helped him keep his head above water. Hours later, he was found and pulled to safety. When News of the Rescue was broadcast on the news, it caught the eye of a woman in a different part of Greece. Ten days earlier, her children had been playing with a ball on a distant beach. One of them kicked the ball a bit too hard in the direction of the ocean and it bobbed away. The boy shrugged and went on playing without their toy.
他紧紧抓住那个半瘪的球，它帮助他保持头部浮在水面上。几小时后，他被发现并获救。当救援的消息在新闻中播出时，它引起了希腊另一位女性的注意。十天前，她的孩子们曾在遥远的海滩上玩球。其中一个孩子踢球时用力过猛，球飞向了大海，随波逐流而去。那个男孩耸了耸肩，没再管他们的玩具，继续玩耍去了。
Watching the news, the boy's mother recognized the ball. It was the one that her sons had lost. It had floated some 80 miles on the ocean, just in time to save Ivan's life. Going about our day-to-day lives, most of us act as if the world is orderly and predictable. We make plans, we set goals, we schedule events. What we don't take into account is the ever-present role of chance and randomness, blind forces
看着新闻，男孩的母亲认出了那个球。那就是她儿子们弄丢的那个。它在海上漂流了约80英里，恰好及时救了伊万一命。在日常生活中，我们大多数人的行为方式仿佛世界是有序且可预测的。我们制定计划，设定目标，安排活动。我们没有考虑到的是偶然性和随机性——那些盲目的力量——无处不在的作用。
that wield more power than we recognize. This week on Hidden Brain, we conclude our Wellness 2.0 series with a look at how we can come to grips with the unpredictable forces that shape our world and turn them to our advantage. We hear a lot these days about separating the signal from the noise. The idea is that there is a deep order, a solid predictability we can count on if only we can screen out distracting details, meaningless static. But what if those trivial random factors actually matter?
它们所拥有的力量远超我们的认知。本周在《Hidden Brain》节目中，我们将结束“健康2.0”系列，探讨我们如何才能掌握塑造世界的不可预测的力量，并将其转化为我们的优势。如今我们经常听到关于从噪音中提取信号的说法。其观点是，只要我们能过滤掉分散注意力的细节和毫无意义的静电干扰，就能找到我们可以依赖的深层秩序和稳固的可预测性。但如果那些微不足道的随机因素实际上很重要呢？
What if they matter a lot? At University College London, political scientist Brian Kloss studies these hidden forces. Brian Kloss, welcome to Hidden Brain. It's a pleasure to be here. Brian, there's a story you like to tell about a young American couple, Mr. and Mrs. H.L. Stimson, who visited Japan almost a century ago.
如果它们非常重要呢？在伦敦大学学院，政治学家布莱恩·克拉斯研究这些隐藏的力量。布莱恩·克拉斯，欢迎来到《Hidden Brain》。很高兴来到这里。布莱恩，你喜欢讲一个关于一对美国年轻夫妇的故事，亨利·L·史汀生夫妇，他们大约一个世纪前访问了日本。
Who were they and what were they doing in that country? Yeah, so there's this couple, this American couple that goes on this sightseeing mission to Kyoto, Japan in 1926 in the autumn. And they do what everybody does when they go on vacation. They sort of see the city. They stay at this place called the Miyako Hotel and Stimson records in his diary
他们是谁？他们在那个国家做什么？是的，有一对美国夫妇，1926年秋天去日本京都进行观光旅行。他们做了每个人度假时都会做的事。他们游览了这座城市。他们住在一家叫都酒店的地方，史汀生在日记中记录道
that they have a quote, beautiful day of sightseeing. And anyone who's been to Kyoto has seen these incredible colors in the autumn, the incredible temples, the sort of charm of this unbelievable city. And the Stimpsons, like everybody else, sort of fall in love with it and they get a soft spot for it. Almost two decades after the Stimpsons visit to Japan, the city of Kyoto becomes the topic of much discussion at the highest levels of the US government. Why were American military leaders fixated on Kyoto, Brian?
他们度过了“美好的一天观光”。任何去过京都的人都见过秋天那令人难以置信的色彩、不可思议的寺庙，以及这座令人难以置信的城市的魅力。史汀生夫妇像其他人一样，爱上了这里，并对它产生了好感。在史汀生夫妇访问日本近二十年后，京都这座城市成为了美国政府最高层讨论的话题。布莱恩，为什么美国军事领导人会盯着京都？
Yeah, so this is the summer of 1945 when they're on the cusp of having the first successful test of the world's first atomic bomb. And they have a choice to make, one of the most difficult and macabre choices that any American government official has ever made, where to use it. And so they have this group of scientists and generals that get together called the Target Committee, and they draft their choices for where they think would be the most effective use of the bomb. And Kyoto is consistently rated as the top choice. It had cultural significance because it was a former imperial capital. It also had an airplane factory that was churning out parts of the Japanese
是的，那是1945年夏天，他们正处于世界上第一颗原子弹试验即将成功的关口。他们必须做出选择，这是美国政府官员有史以来做出的最困难、最可怕的选择之一：在哪里使用它。于是，他们召集了一群科学家和将军，组成了一个“目标委员会”，起草了他们认为最能有效使用原子弹的地点。京都一直被评为首选。它具有文化意义，因为它是前帝国首都。它还有一个制造日本军事力量零部件的飞机工厂。
military force. And so it had military significance. You have the fact that it's relatively undamaged by previous American bombing. And on top of it, they even discuss how there's a university there, and therefore they'll have the educated people of Kyoto will understand that a new chapter in human history has been opened with the dropping of this extraordinarily powerful weapon. So Kyoto is now at the top of this target list, but our Kyoto tourist by this point has become something of an important figure. Tell me what Henry Stimson was up to at this stage.
因此它具有军事意义。此外，它之前几乎没有受到美国轰炸的破坏。最重要的是，他们甚至讨论到那里有一所大学，因此京都受过教育的人们会明白，随着这种威力巨大的武器的投下，人类历史翻开了新的一章。所以京都现在排在目标名单的首位，但我们的京都游客此时已成为重要人物。告诉我亨利·史汀生在这个阶段在做什么。
Yeah, so 19 years after he goes on vacation to Kyoto, Stimson has risen through the ranks of the US government, and he is now the Secretary of War in 1945. And that means he's the chief civilian who oversees the target committee, who oversees the decision of where to drop the atomic bomb. And he gets this memo, and we have all these memos preserved through historical records. And the memo basically says, you know We agree Kyoto must be destroyed. That's where we're going to drop the first atomic bomb. Hmm What was his reaction when he saw that memo? well
是的，在他去京都度假19年后，史汀生在美国政府中步步高升，到1945年他已是战争部长。这意味着他是监督目标委员会的最高文职官员，负责监督在哪里投下原子弹的决定。他收到了一份备忘录，我们通过历史记录保存了所有这些备忘录。备忘录基本上说：“我们同意必须摧毁京都。那就是我们要投下第一颗原子弹的地方。”嗯，他看到那份备忘录时有什么反应？嗯
we don't know exactly what happened the moment he saw the memo but we know that he sprung to action because The generals began to refer to Kyoto as Stimson's pet city, because he had gone to such extraordinary lengths to try to save it. And that involved sending messages, it involved twice meeting with President Truman, the American president at the time, overseeing this choice, and convincing him to take Kyoto off the bombing list. So it's an extraordinary intervention
我们不知道他看到备忘录那一刻究竟发生了什么，但我们知道他立即采取了行动，因为将军们开始称京都为“史汀生的宠物城市”，因为他为了拯救它付出了非凡的努力。这包括发送信息，两次会见当时的美国总统杜鲁门（他负责监督这一选择），并说服他将京都从轰炸名单中剔除。所以这是一次非凡的干预
by a government official, who is basically going out on a limb to overrule the decision of the committee that has deeply thought about the strategic value of various bombing targets. Hmm. So at one point, of course, as you just mentioned, Henry Stimson goes about the heads of the generals, speaks to President Truman, has two meetings with him, and finally convinces Truman that Kyoto should be taken off the list. What were the Japanese cities that were left on this potential bombing list, Brian? Yeah, so the first target is taken off the list, Kyoto. So they go to the secondary targets on August 6th, 1945. The other one that was very highly rated and that was Hiroshima, which as we all know was
由一位政府官员做出，他基本上是冒着风险推翻了委员会的决定，而该委员会曾深入思考过各种轰炸目标的战略价值。嗯。所以正如你刚才提到的，亨利·史汀生越过将军们，与杜鲁门总统交谈，与他进行了两次会面，最终说服杜鲁门将京都从名单中剔除。布莱恩，名单上还剩下哪些日本城市？是的，第一个目标被从名单上剔除了，即京都。所以他们在1945年8月6日转向次要目标。另一个评价很高的是广岛，众所周知，它
destroyed by the first atomic bomb. The second target that was of significance that was deemed to be one of the top value targets was a place called Kokura. And that was where the second atomic bomb on August 9th, 1945, three days after the Hiroshima bombing, was supposed to go. So the second B-29 boxcar is approaching Kokura, ready to drop its payload, and the city is obscured
被第一颗原子弹摧毁了。第二个被认为是最有价值的目标之一的地方叫小仓。那是1945年8月9日，即广岛轰炸三天后，第二颗原子弹原定要投下的地方。所以第二架B-29轰炸机“博克斯卡”号正在接近小仓，准备投下它的载荷，但城市被
by unforecasted fog and clouds and haze. So basically they can't see the bomb site. And as a result of this, they think to themselves, well, we can't risk dropping an atomic bomb and missing. So they circle a few times and eventually they decide to divert to the secondary target as they're running low on fuel and that is Nagasaki. And so around 1045 in the morning they drop the second atomic bomb on Nagasaki, Japan. And of course nobody in Kokura was aware of this. And so there's a term in modern Japanese culture called Kokura's luck, which is basically when you unknowingly escape disaster.
未预报的雾、云和霾遮挡了。基本上他们看不到轰炸点。因此，他们心想，我们不能冒着投下原子弹却打偏的风险。所以他们盘旋了几次，最终决定转向次要目标，因为燃料不足，那就是长崎。于是，在上午10点45分左右，他们在日本长崎投下了第二颗原子弹。当然，小仓没有人意识到这一点。所以现代日本文化中有一个词叫“小仓的运气”，基本上是指在不知情的情况下逃脱灾难。
Because for potentially 100,000, maybe even more people living in that city, they were spared by a passing cloud. And for the people of Kyoto, they were spared by a 19-year-old vacation of one pivotal government official who was at the right place at the right time. So besides Kokura's luck, you might also say Nagasaki had especially bad luck because in fact, it was the removal of Kyoto from the list that brought Nagasaki onto the list in the first place
因为对于那个城市里可能多达10万甚至更多的人来说，他们被一片飘过的云救了。而对于京都的人民来说，他们被一位关键政府官员19年前的一次度假所拯救，他出现在了正确的时间和正确的地点。所以除了“小仓的运气”，你也可以说长崎的运气特别差，因为事实上，正是因为京都从名单中被移除，才导致长崎被列入名单
and then the cloud cover over Kokura prompted the bomb to be dropped over Nagasaki. That seems extraordinarily unfortunate, Brian. This is the nature of luck, is that it's in the eye of the beholder because one person's luck is somebody else's misfortune. Certainly, it's the case that with Nagasaki, if there had been a decision to drop the bomb on Kyoto, then the secondary target probably would have been Hiroshima. And so there's this sort of cascade of effects, this vacation, which is intersecting with this cloud. All these things had to come together, not to mention the timing of when they discovered the atomic bomb, the discovery of uranium, all of them connected to create that
然后小仓上空的云层促使炸弹投向了长崎。布莱恩，这看起来极其不幸。这就是运气的本质，它在旁观者的眼中，因为一个人的运气是另一个人的不幸。当然，对于长崎来说，如果当时决定在京都投下炸弹，那么次要目标可能就是广岛。所以这是一种连锁反应，这次度假与这片云交织在一起。所有这些事情必须结合在一起，更不用说他们发现原子弹的时间、铀的发现，所有这些都连接起来，创造了那个
moment of intense misfortune for the people who were unfortunately killed in both Hiroshima and Nagasaki. But when you tell me that the fate of tens of thousands of people was partly or perhaps even significantly determined by a vacation that two Americans took decades earlier, there's a part of me that recoils at that brine. There's a part of me that feels that is immoral. Yeah, and this is something that, you know, when you get to these highly consequential events of warfare, of mass destruction, weapons being used and so on, there is obviously a moral component.
对那些不幸在广岛和长崎丧生的人来说极其不幸的时刻。但当你告诉我，成千上万人的命运在某种程度上，甚至可能是很大程度上，是由两个美国人几十年前的一次度假决定的，我内心的一部分对此感到反感，布莱恩。我内心的一部分觉得这不道德。是的，这是……你知道，当你谈到战争、大规模杀伤、武器使用等这些后果极其严重的事件时，显然存在道德成分。
And yet I think there's also an aspect of this that shows the amoral components of some of these interconnecting factors. And that's because there's nothing immoral about going on vacation, but it produces this outcome that leads to an immoral action. The way I sometimes think about this is, you could go outside tomorrow and plant a tree, and 100 years from now, a kid could fall out of it and die. It doesn't make your action immoral, right?
然而，我认为这其中也有一个方面展示了这些相互关联因素的非道德成分。这是因为去度假本身并没有什么不道德，但它产生了一个导致不道德行为的结果。我有时这样想：你明天可以出去种一棵树，100年后，一个孩子可能会从树上掉下来摔死。这并不会让你的行为变得不道德，对吧？
It just underlines the fact that the interconnectivity of the world means that unexpected and sometimes deeply problematic things arise from the smallest of human choices. I want to talk about a very different story, Brian. Now this one is personal to you. Take us back in time again to a small town in Wisconsin in 1905. Something terrible happened there June of that year. Tell me the story.
这只是强调了一个事实，即世界的相互关联性意味着微小的人类选择会产生意想不到的、有时是极其严重的问题。我想谈谈一个非常不同的故事，布莱恩。这个故事对你来说很私密。让我们再次回到1905年的威斯康星州的一个小镇。那年6月发生了一件可怕的事情。讲讲这个故事。
Yeah, so it's the summer of 1905 in a little place in Wisconsin, a little farmhouse. And there's a woman named Clara Modlin Janssen who lives on the farm with her four young children and her husband. And the oldest child at this point is four years old. And if you do the math with four young children and a four year old,
是的，那是1905年的夏天，在威斯康星州的一个小地方，一个农舍里。有一个叫克拉拉·莫德林·詹森的女人，她和四个年幼的孩子以及丈夫住在农场里。当时最大的孩子才四岁。如果你算一下，有四个年幼的孩子，最大的才四岁，
I mean, she's been having kids basically nonstop. And at some point, the stress, perhaps the burden of being a mother for these four young children overwhelms her and she snaps. And she has a mental health breakdown and takes this horrible decision to take the lives of her four young children before taking her own life. And so the husband comes home, Clara's husband comes home and discovers that most horrific thing that any human can experience the single moment where his entire family has been wiped out in this intense act of murderous tragedy and all of them are
我的意思是，她基本上一直在不停地生孩子。在某个时刻，压力，也许是作为这四个年幼孩子的母亲的负担压垮了她，她崩溃了。她精神失常，做出了一个可怕的决定，在结束自己的生命之前，夺走了她四个年幼孩子的生命。所以丈夫回家了，克拉拉的丈夫回家后发现了任何人类所能经历的最可怕的事情——他的整个家庭在这一场激烈的谋杀悲剧中被抹去，所有人都
dead and so you know he can only imagine what that was like. The reason I tell that story is because the man who came home to that farmhouse was my great grandfather and what is really striking about it from my perspective is that because my great-grandfather remarried about a decade later to the woman that became my great-grandmother, I literally would not exist if those kids did not die. It's my sort of version of Kokura's luck in a bizarre way
死了，所以你知道，他只能想象那是什么感觉。我讲这个故事的原因是，那个回到农舍的男人是我的曾祖父，从我的角度来看，真正令人震惊的是，因为我的曾祖父在大约十年后与后来成为我曾祖母的女人再婚，如果那些孩子没有死，我根本就不会存在。这在某种程度上是我版本的“小仓的运气”，非常离奇
that every joy of my life, every moment of my life indeed, is predicated on this horrible event. It gives you a lesson, I think, that the worst moments of your life are inextricably linked to the best moments of your life, and that the good and bads of our life end up creating future joy and future pain and we can't do anything about that. A man is swept out to sea and he is saved because a little boy kicked his ball into the ocean. Tens of thousands of people in Nagasaki are killed while their brothers and sisters in Kyoto are spared because of a sightseeing trip. Someone exists today because four children and their mother perished a century ago.
我生命中的每一个快乐，事实上我生命中的每一个时刻，都是建立在这个可怕的事件之上的。我认为这给了你一个教训：你生命中最糟糕的时刻与你生命中最美好的时刻是密不可分的，我们生活中的好与坏最终创造了未来的快乐和未来的痛苦，我们对此无能为力。一个男人被冲入大海，因为一个小男孩把球踢进了大海而获救。长崎成千上万的人被杀害，而他们在京都的兄弟姐妹却因为一次观光旅行而幸免于难。今天有人存在，是因为一个世纪前四个孩子和他们的母亲丧生了。
We like to imagine that we live in an orderly universe that is occasionally upended by an unexpected event. But what if those unforeseeable occurrences are the rule, not the exception. When we come back, why we fail to recognize that we live in a world of randomness and what we should do about it. You're listening to Hidden Brain. I'm Shankar Vedantam. This is Hidden Brain. I'm Shankar Vedantam. At University College London, political scientist Brian Klaas long subscribed to a view that most of us have, that history and politics are shaped by powerful people and predictable currents. Brian as a political scientist, you studied the way power operates. A few years ago, you went on a research trip that made you question whether many of the assumptions and theories of your field were accurate.
我们喜欢想象我们生活在一个有序的宇宙中，偶尔会被突发事件颠覆。但如果那些不可预见的事件是常态，而不是例外呢？回来后，我们将探讨为什么我们未能认识到我们生活在一个随机的世界中，以及我们应该对此做些什么。你正在收听《Hidden Brain》。我是尚卡尔·维丹塔姆。这里是《Hidden Brain》。我是尚卡尔·维丹塔姆。在伦敦大学学院，政治学家布莱恩·克拉斯长期以来认同我们大多数人的观点，即历史和政治是由权势人物和可预测的潮流所塑造的。布莱恩，作为一名政治学家，你研究了权力的运作方式。几年前，你去进行了一次研究旅行，这让你质疑你所在领域的许多假设和理论是否准确。
You visited Zambia to study a coup. What was the story you'd heard about Zambia before you went, and what did you find when you got there? Yeah, I was studying the origin stories of a coup d'etat, a military takeover of the government, and the official version of events was that basically a drunken idiot had tried to take power from the Zambian military in 1997. So I went to figure out what had really happened. And what turned out to be the case was that the plot was a lot more sophisticated than I originally had realized. So what they were planning to do was to kidnap the army commander, the top military general in Zambia, and force him at gunpoint to announce the coup on the radio.
你访问了赞比亚去研究一场政变。在你去之前，你听到的关于赞比亚的故事是什么？当你到达那里时，你发现了什么？是的，我当时正在研究政变（军事接管政府）的起源故事，官方版本的事件是，基本上是一个醉酒的白痴在1997年试图从赞比亚军队手中夺取政权。所以我去弄清楚到底发生了什么。结果发现，阴谋比我最初意识到的要复杂得多。他们计划做的是绑架陆军指挥官，即赞比亚的最高军事将领，并用枪指着他，强迫他在广播中宣布政变。
And I'm assuming at this point that if other people in the military hear the top commander say there has been a coup, I surrender, they would basically fall in line. That's exactly right. So that was the plan. And so I talked to some of the soldiers involved in the coup and I asked them what they did and they went out to the army commander's house in the middle of the night, you know, something like three in the morning. And he sort of hears these noises and runs out, presumably in his pajamas, out the back of the compound and starts climbing up the wall. And one of the soldiers I interviewed describes how he grabs the sort of pant leg or trouser leg of the army commander and the commander
我假设在这一点上，如果军队中的其他人听到最高指挥官说发生了政变，我投降，他们基本上会顺从。完全正确。这就是计划。所以我采访了一些参与政变的士兵，我问他们做了什么，他们在大半夜，大概凌晨三点左右，去了陆军指挥官的家。他听到了这些声音，跑了出来，大概穿着睡衣，从大院后面跑出来，开始爬墙。我采访的一名士兵描述了他如何抓住陆军指挥官的裤腿，而指挥官
is pulling up on the wall trying to climb over and he's pulling down. And in this instant, the sort of fabric slips through his fingers. And as a result, the commander clambers over the wall, rushes to the government house where the sort of government headquarters are, and alerts them to this coup plot underway. So he slipped through their fingers by chance and the coup plot fails catastrophically. They find the ringleader hiding in a trash can three hours later. I mean, it's this like clownishly disastrous ending to the story. But it taught me a lot about the way that we understand the world. Because what stuck with me and was always just sort of in the back of my mind when I was trying
正向上拉，试图爬过去，而他正向下拉。就在这一瞬间，布料从他指间滑落。结果，指挥官爬过了墙，冲向了政府总部所在的政府大楼，并向他们通报了正在进行的政变阴谋。所以他偶然从他们手中溜走了，政变阴谋彻底失败了。三小时后，他们发现主谋躲在垃圾桶里。我的意思是，这个故事的结局简直是滑稽的灾难。但这教会了我很多关于我们理解世界的方式。因为让我印象深刻，并且在我试图
to practice social science as I do professionally is if they had just been a millisecond faster, that they would have actually captured Zambia's government. And that when I was taught all about models and data, and you know, trend lines and so on, the details, what people would call the noise is what I thought was really, really important in that coup plot. And it was all reduced to one number, which was zero, a failed coup plot. And of course, when people build models of political instability, and how coups succeed and how coups fail, they're not taking into account whether someone's trousers are slippery. This is the big problem of social research and why it's so unbelievably difficult to do effectively.
进行专业社会科学研究时一直萦绕在心头的是，如果他们哪怕快了一毫秒，他们实际上就会夺取赞比亚的政府。当我被教导关于模型、数据、趋势线等等时，细节——人们称之为“噪音”的东西——才是我认为在那个政变阴谋中真正重要的东西。而这一切都被简化为一个数字，即零，一个失败的政变阴谋。当然，当人们建立政治不稳定模型，以及政变如何成功和失败时，他们并没有考虑到某人的裤子是否滑。这是社会研究的一大难题，也是为什么它如此难以有效进行的原因。
Because if you were trying to model where the atomic bomb is going to be dropped, you wouldn't include the vacation histories of US government officials. But all of these things matter. And what I've realized is that intuitively, when we think about the trajectories of our own lives, we take this stuff seriously. When we think about how we met a partner, why we ended up going to this school rather than that school, the little bits of noise always matter in our life histories. the little bits of noise always matter in our life histories. When we aggregate it out to the social level and we try to make predictions and talk about trends and so on, all that detail gets treated as though it's meaningless.
因为如果你试图模拟原子弹将在哪里投下，你不会把美国政府官员的度假历史包括进去。但所有这些事情都很重要。我意识到，直觉上，当我们思考自己人生的轨迹时，我们认真对待这些东西。当我们思考我们是如何遇到伴侣的，为什么我们最终去了这所学校而不是那所学校，那些小小的噪音总是对我们的人生历史很重要。那些小小的噪音总是对我们的人生历史很重要。当我们将其汇总到社会层面，试图做出预测并谈论趋势时，所有这些细节都被视为毫无意义。
And my argument in a nutshell is that that is a mistake, that the noise is really important because the small changes can create massive social differences over time. can create massive social differences over time. So if the world is actually shaped by randomness and chance, but we managed to tell ourselves a tidy story about how it's governed by predictable rules and principles, let's talk about some of the factors inside the brain that make this shift possible. You've observed that there are biases wired into the brain that lead us to overlook the influence of small or random influences. One of these is the
我的观点简而言之就是这是一个错误，噪音非常重要，因为微小的变化会随着时间的推移产生巨大的社会差异。会随着时间的推移产生巨大的社会差异。所以，如果世界实际上是由随机性和偶然性塑造的，但我们设法告诉自己一个关于它如何受可预测规则和原则支配的整洁故事，让我们谈谈大脑内部使这种转变成为可能的因素。你观察到大脑中存在一些偏见，导致我们忽视了微小或随机影响的作用。其中之一是
so-called magnitude bias. What is this, Brian? The magnitude bias is the belief, often the false belief, that any big event must have a big cause that triggers it. So if there's a war, if there's an assassination, if there is a major shift in society of any sort, or indeed if our lives are upended, that there must be some big explanation. And so we've basically got brains that are evolved to gravitate towards large explanations for large events. And it's really unsatisfying to think large explanations for large events. And it's really unsatisfying to think the opposite, right? So one of the ways that this manifests is in conspiracy thinking.
所谓的“量级偏见”。布莱恩，这是什么？量级偏见是一种信念，通常是错误的信念，即任何重大事件必然有一个触发它的重大原因。所以如果发生了一场战争，如果发生了一次暗杀，如果社会发生了任何形式的重大转变，或者确实如果我们的生活被颠覆了，那么必然有一个重大的解释。所以我们基本上拥有进化出来的大脑，倾向于为重大事件寻找重大解释。认为相反的情况是非常令人不满的，对吧？所以这表现出来的方式之一就是阴谋论思维。
And if you think about Princess Diana's death, this is one of my favorite studies that goes to the cognitive psychology of this. A lot of people in Britain looked at what they saw as an extremely momentous world event of Princess Diana dying. And the idea that a car accident, something so banal and so arbitrary as a car accident, could be behind this was so unsatisfying that a lot of
如果你想想戴安娜王妃的去世，这是我最喜欢的关于认知心理学的研究之一。英国的许多人看着他们所认为的戴安娜王妃去世这一极其重大的世界事件。认为一场车祸——如此平庸且如此随意的车祸——可能是背后的原因，这太令人不满，以至于许多
people when they were being studied for their beliefs on what had actually happened, will happily take large explanations even if they're mutually contradictory. So people who are conspiratorial thinkers will sometimes say that, we think that she's still alive and also we think that she was killed by the government. And both of those can't be true but they're totally unsatisfied with the notion of an arbitrary or an accidental explanation. Hmm. I mean even in the story that you just told me about the Stimpsons and their vacation to Japan, you know as you're telling me the story I'm recoiling at the idea that someone's vacation can decide where an atomic bomb is dropped
人在被研究他们对实际发生的事情的看法时，会很乐意接受重大的解释，即使它们是相互矛盾的。所以阴谋论者有时会说，我们认为她还活着，我们也认为她是被政府杀害的。这两者不可能同时为真，但他们对随意或偶然的解释完全不满意。嗯。我的意思是，即使在你刚才告诉我的关于史汀生夫妇去日本度假的故事中，你知道，当你给我讲这个故事时，我对有人度假就能决定在哪里投下原子弹的想法感到反感
You know surely I tell myself there have to be bigger causes driving this. It can't be something so trivial Yeah, but you know if you go back further all of this is this intersection of tiny events I mean it sometimes I'll say things like, you know, have you ever heard of Albert Einstein's grandmother? It's like, no. Well, she was really important because if she didn't exist, Albert Einstein doesn't exist. So you sort of, the more that you end up looking for explanations, you end up in what's called
你知道，我肯定告诉自己，一定有更大的原因在驱动这一切。不可能是这么琐碎的事情。是的，但你知道，如果你追溯得更远，这一切都是微小事件的交集。我的意思是，有时我会说一些话，比如，你听说过阿尔伯特·爱因斯坦的祖母吗？就像，没有。嗯，她非常重要，因为如果她不存在，阿尔伯特·爱因斯坦就不存在。所以你，你越是寻找解释，你最终就会陷入所谓的
an infinite regress, which is where there's another explanation and then that has another explanation behind it. And that has another explanation behind it. And what you ultimately end up with when you're making truthful assessments of what happened is that there's an infinite number of causes, many of them tiny, but all of them essential because if you take them away you probably wouldn't end up with the same outcome. And of course if you take the even longer view and you look at the
“无限倒退”，即有一个解释，然后那个解释背后还有另一个解释。而那个背后还有另一个解释。当你对发生的事情进行真实的评估时，你最终得到的是有无数个原因，其中许多是微小的，但它们都是必不可少的，因为如果你把它们拿走，你可能就不会得到同样的结果。当然，如果你看得更长远，看看
evolution of humans in the first place, the number of chance occurrences that must have had to take place for that to happen is extraordinary. This is one of my favorite sections of my research is that I'm looking at all these crazy aspects of human evolution, but for this one thing, we wouldn't exist. My favorite is the asteroid that wiped out the dinosaurs because the best science we have today suggests that an oscillation in this part of space called the Oort cloud flung a space rock towards earth and it hit in the worst possible place from the perspective of the dinosaurs and the best possible place from the perspective of humans just off the Yucatan peninsula
人类的进化，为了让它发生，必须发生的偶然事件的数量是惊人的。这是我研究中最喜欢的部分之一，我正在研究人类进化的所有这些疯狂方面，但如果没有这一件事，我们就不会存在。我最喜欢的是消灭恐龙的小行星，因为我们今天拥有的最好的科学表明，太空这一部分被称为奥尔特云的振荡将一块太空岩石抛向地球，它击中了从恐龙的角度来看最糟糕的地方，而从人类的角度来看则是最好的地方，就在尤卡坦半岛附近
in what is this rock that is very rich with gypsum. And so the impact creates obviously some devastation, but what really wiped out the dinosaurs was this toxic gas along with the heat. And so if it had hit anywhere else on the planet, or if it had been delayed by a few seconds it probably would have missed the earth, humans almost certainly would not exist, right? Mammals would not have risen as the sort of dominant player after the extinction of the dinosaurs. This is constantly happening. My other favorite story of this type from evolutionary biology is the origin story of live births and the sort of emergence of placenta. That is, according to
在这一块富含石膏的岩石中。所以撞击显然造成了一些破坏，但真正消灭恐龙的是这种有毒气体和热量。所以如果它击中了地球上的任何其他地方，或者如果它延迟了几秒钟，它很可能就会错过地球，人类几乎肯定不会存在，对吧？哺乳动物不会在恐龙灭绝后崛起成为某种主导者。这种情况一直在发生。我最喜欢的这类进化生物学故事是活产的起源和胎盘的出现。根据
the best genomics research we have today, derived from a single chance event where one shrew-like creature got infected with a retrovirus about 100 million years ago, and this is why mammals don't lay eggs, right? And you sort of think, I mean, it's such a profound evolutionary change, maybe we wouldn't exist if not for this one shrew-like creature
我们今天拥有的最好的基因组学研究，这源于一个单一的偶然事件，大约1亿年前，一种类似鼩鼱的生物感染了一种逆转录病毒，这就是为什么哺乳动物不产卵，对吧？你可能会想，我的意思是，这是一个如此深刻的进化变化，如果没有这个类似鼩鼱的生物，我们可能就不会存在
100 million years ago. It's a very humbling thing to look into these backgrounds because the fragility, not just of your individual existence through the maddening random chance that leads to you being born rather than somebody else from your parents, but also just humanity's existence is incredibly, incredibly fragile. So in the middle of the last century, scientists in a number of fields began to recognize that contrary to our assumptions, very small influences could produce very big effects. One of the researchers who first drew attention to this reality was named Edward Lorenz.
1亿年前。研究这些背景是一件非常令人谦卑的事情，因为脆弱性，不仅是你通过导致你出生而不是你父母的其他人的疯狂随机偶然性而存在的个人脆弱性，而且人类的存在也是极其、极其脆弱的。所以，在上个世纪中叶，许多领域的科学家开始认识到，与我们的假设相反，非常微小的影响可以产生非常大的影响。最早引起人们注意这一现实的研究人员之一名叫爱德华·洛伦兹。
Who was he, Brian, and what was his story? So Edward Lorenz is a fascinating character because he accidentally ended up in meteorology during World War II, when Uncle Sam was sort of drafting everyone into the military effort. Lorenz was a really bright guy and he had an interest in the weather, so he joined up and ended up, believe it or not, working on forecasting weather during American bombing rains in the late stages of World War II in Japan. Now, after the war ends, he's sort of aware that there's some really limited computing power involved in forecasting, and we really don't know how we can predict the future of whether it's really arbitrary and really poor quality. So he starts to invent a weather computer and tries his best to improve forecasting
布莱恩，他是谁？他的故事是什么？爱德华·洛伦兹是一个迷人的人物，因为他在二战期间意外地进入了气象学领域，当时山姆大叔正在把每个人都征召进军事行动。洛伦兹是一个非常聪明的人，他对天气很感兴趣，所以他加入了，信不信由你，在二战后期日本的美国轰炸期间从事天气预报工作。现在，战争结束后，他意识到预报中涉及的计算能力非常有限，我们真的不知道如何预测天气，它是非常随意且质量非常差的。所以他开始发明一台天气计算机，并尽最大努力改进预报
of how we might be able to predict the weather. So he has this really rudimentary computer that can only handle a few variables. I think it was about 12 variables of the weather. So maybe you've got temperature and wind speed and so on. And he plugs them into this computer, this sort of early computer and runs a simulation. And one day he decides to rerun the simulation
我们可能如何预测天气。所以他有一台非常简陋的计算机，只能处理几个变量。我想大约是12个天气变量。所以也许你有温度、风速等等。他把它们输入到这台计算机中，这种早期的计算机，并运行了一个模拟。有一天，他决定重新运行模拟
starting from halfway through. But he sort of groans and doesn't really want to start all the way at the beginning, it will take too long. So he figures, I'll just start halfway. I'll look at the computer printout for the data for all of the variables in the model. I'll type them in exactly, and I'll rerun the simulation starting from halfway through.
从中间开始。但他呻吟着，真的不想从头开始，那太花时间了。所以他想，我就从中间开始吧。我会查看模型中所有变量数据的计算机打印输出。我会准确地输入它们，然后从中间开始重新运行模拟。
And what he sees, we can only imagine he's got this sort of befuddled look as he looks at the screen, because the data is completely different. The weather patterns have changed radically from simulation one to simulation two, even though they're using the same data. And what he finds after a lot of sort of chin scratching is that the numbers that were printed out ended after three decimal places. So imagine that you've got a number like 1.234. It would be printed as 1.234, but the actual number might be 1.23456789.
他所看到的，我们只能想象他看着屏幕时那种困惑的表情，因为数据完全不同。天气模式从模拟一到模拟二发生了根本性的变化，尽管它们使用的是相同的数据。经过一番抓耳挠腮，他发现打印出来的数字在小数点后三位就结束了。所以想象一下你有一个数字，比如1.234。它会被打印为1.234，但实际数字可能是1.23456789。
And so in losing those little tiny numbers after the third decimal place, what Lorenz realized was that that was where the weather was diverging. And this is the origin story of a realm of science called chaos theory, where you realize that these tiny changes over time can have profound consequences.
所以，在丢失了小数点后那几个微小的数字后，洛伦兹意识到，那就是天气发生分歧的地方。这就是被称为“混沌理论”的科学领域的起源故事，在那里你意识到这些微小的变化随着时间的推移会产生深远的影响。
And it's by the way, the reason why today, even with the best supercomputers, we cannot forecast the weather reliably beyond seven to 10 days. And that's because we can't measure everything absolutely perfectly. There's always going to be these little variations. And that's because we can't measure everything absolutely perfectly. There's always going to be these little variations. And that's the difference between a forecast being correct two weeks down the road and being wildly off.
顺便说一句，这就是为什么今天，即使有最好的超级计算机，我们也无法可靠地预测7到10天以后的天气。这是因为我们无法绝对完美地测量一切。总是会有这些微小的变化。这是因为我们无法绝对完美地测量一切。总是会有这些微小的变化。这就是两周后的预报正确与完全错误之间的区别。
One reason we don't see the hand of chaos is that we are often quick to explain things in a way that makes them seem predictable. Brian says this is because our brains are storytelling machines. Evolution has designed us to come up with explanations for the things we see and hear. So imagine that you are a sort of pre-modern hunter-gatherer and you see this little rustling in the grass, or you hear this rustling in the grass. Now, your brain could either decide it's probably nothing and just carry on with your day, or your brain could say, okay, hold on, this might be a saber-toothed tiger, this might be a predator. Now, if you happen to make a mistake
我们看不到混沌之手的另一个原因是，我们往往很快就会以一种使事情看起来可预测的方式来解释它们。布莱恩说这是因为我们的大脑是讲故事的机器。进化设计了我们，让我们为所见所闻寻找解释。所以想象一下，你是一个前现代的狩猎采集者，你看到草丛里有轻微的沙沙声，或者你听到草丛里有沙沙声。现在，你的大脑要么决定这可能没什么，继续你的一天，要么你的大脑会说，好吧，等等，这可能是一只剑齿虎，这可能是一个捕食者。现在，如果你碰巧犯了一个错误
and you think it is a saber-toothed tiger when it's not, you will survive and maybe waste a little bit of energy by running away. But if you make the other kind of mistake, if you think it's nothing and it turns out to be a saber-toothed tiger, you will die. So our brains have evolved to overemphasize patterns and this helps us survive because you're more attuned to what might be a threat. But it also means that we see patterns where they don't necessarily exist. And this creates a mismatch with modern life where we make mistakes because we believe things to be true that simply are uncorrelated clusters of data that we sort of connect the dots between.
你认为它是剑齿虎而它不是，你会活下来，也许通过逃跑浪费了一点能量。但如果你犯了另一种错误，如果你认为它没什么，结果却是一只剑齿虎，你就会死。所以我们的大脑已经进化到过度强调模式，这有助于我们生存，因为你对可能存在的威胁更加敏感。但这也意味着我们在不一定存在的地方看到了模式。这与现代生活产生了不匹配，我们犯了错误，因为我们相信那些实际上只是我们连接点之间的不相关数据簇的事情是真实的。
And this must be why when you watch cable television about, you know, the stock market or even about sports, you have people very, very confidently explain why the game turned out the way it did. Why stock A, you know, rose yesterday and why stock B fell 15 points yesterday. It's the same phenomenon. Yeah, so I find this both from sort of an observational point of view and also from participating in this world of forecasting and punditry. On the observational side, I think, you know, when you look at something like the stock market, you know, 8 billion interacting humans producing a global economy, and then some analysts will say, well, stocks are reacting today, this one piece of news, and you're like, really?
这一定就是为什么当你观看关于股票市场甚至体育的有线电视时，你会看到人们非常、非常自信地解释比赛为什么会那样结束。为什么股票A昨天上涨，为什么股票B昨天下跌了15点。这是同样的现象。是的，我从观察的角度以及参与这个预测和评论的世界中都发现了这一点。在观察方面，我认为，当你观察像股票市场这样的东西时，80亿相互作用的人类产生了一个全球经济，然后一些分析师会说，好吧，股票今天在反应，这一条新闻，你会想，真的吗？
Like out of 8 billion people, this one thing is what's causing the market to move in this exact way. And of course, if it had moved the other way, you would have just come up with an explanation that also fits that. But when I end up going on television to talk about politics or social change, I've been really aware that one thing I can't really say, and I've never told this,
就像在80亿人中，这一件事就是导致市场以这种确切方式移动的原因。当然，如果它向另一个方向移动，你也会得出一个同样符合逻辑的解释。但当我最终上电视谈论政治或社会变革时，我非常清楚一件事，我不能真正说出来，而且我从来没有说过这个，
but it's sort of the implicit norm of this world, is you can't say, I don't know. And I don't know a lot of the time, because the world is really complicated. It's really complex. So it reinforces the bias because it's what we crave the most from the people who seemingly are the smartest among us, when in actual fact, the smartest people are the ones who are most prone to saying, I don't know. There's a movie that came out in 1998 that brought the reality of these choices into sharp relief.
但这基本上是这个世界的隐含规范，你不能说“我不知道”。而且很多时候我确实不知道，因为世界真的很复杂。它真的很复杂。所以它强化了偏见，因为这是我们从那些看似最聪明的人身上最渴望得到的东西，而实际上，最聪明的人是那些最倾向于说“我不知道”的人。1998年上映的一部电影将这些选择的现实带入了鲜明的对比。
I want to play you a clip from the trailer of Sliding Doors. Have you ever wondered what might have been? Would things be different if you caught the train instead of missing it? How much would your life change if you were 10 minutes early? You're a fan of this movie, Brian. Tell me how it speaks to all our lives. So Sliding Doors tells us something really important, which is that the moments that we believe to be consequential, those sort of what if moments,
我想给你播放一段《滑动门》预告片的片段。你有没有想过如果当初会怎样？如果你赶上了火车而不是错过了它，事情会有所不同吗？如果你早到10分钟，你的生活会改变多少？你是这部电影的粉丝，布莱恩。告诉我们它如何与我们所有人的生活产生共鸣。所以《滑动门》告诉了我们一件非常重要的事情，那就是我们认为重要的时刻，那些所谓的“如果当初”时刻，
those are the tip of the iceberg, right? They're the ones where we're aware that our lives have diverted. And the point that I'm making is that that is happening literally 100% of the time. When I talk to people about the ideas that I'm grappling with, I often will say, all of you sort of have these moments
那些是冰山一角，对吧？它们是我们意识到生活已经分叉的时刻。而我提出的观点是，这种情况实际上100%的时间都在发生。当我与人们谈论我正在努力解决的想法时，我经常会说，你们所有人都有这些时刻
where you know that something could have been different, where you could have turned left rather than right when you got into a car accident, or you could have gone to the bar, or not gone to the bar, and that's when you met your spouse. The problem is that those are not the sliding doors moments.
你知道事情本可以有所不同，你本可以在发生车祸时向左转而不是向右转，或者你本可以去酒吧，或者不去酒吧，而那就是你遇到配偶的时候。问题是，那些并不是“滑动门”时刻。
The sliding doors moments are the ones that we don't know that our life has diverged. That every moment you have, every little quip you make in conversation diverts the conversation. Every little decision you make, whether to leave the house now or in five minutes, changes the kinds of people you'll meet that day, the conversations you'll have,
所谓“滑动门”时刻，就是那些我们并未察觉到人生已经发生分岔的瞬间。你经历的每一个时刻，你在谈话中随口说的每一句俏皮话，都会让谈话走向不同的方向。你做的每一个小决定，无论是现在出门还是五分钟后再出门，都会改变你那天会遇到的人、会进行的谈话，
and those ripple effects emanate throughout our lives. And so one of the biggest mistakes I think we make is that only big things matter and only things we're aware of matter. And those are both completely wrong. So all of the time, every single moment of our lives is reshaping our futures. And we intuitively understand this whenever we encounter science fiction that involves time travel. Because if you're going to go back in time, everyone gives you the same warning, right? Don't touch anything. Don't squish a bug a million years ago because you'll delete humans from the future. Or don't talk to your parents because you'll never get born. So they understand in that logic
而这些连锁反应会贯穿我们的一生。我认为我们犯下的最大错误之一，就是认为只有大事才重要，只有我们意识到的事情才重要。这两者都是完全错误的。所以，我们生命中的每一刻都在重塑我们的未来。每当我们接触到涉及时间旅行的科幻作品时，我们都会直观地理解这一点。因为如果你要回到过去，每个人都会给你同样的警告，对吧？什么都别碰。千万别在一百万年前踩死一只虫子，因为那会抹杀未来的全人类。或者别和你的父母说话，因为那样你就永远不会出生。所以他们明白这种逻辑，
that every little detail matters. Cause and effect happens the same whether it's in the past, the present, or the future. So if squishing a bug a million years ago can reshape the world, squishing a bug today can reshape the world. If talking to someone million years ago can reshape the world, squishing a bug today can reshape the world. If talking to someone 50 years ago can reshape who's born, talking to someone today can reshape who's born in 50 years. And that is a bewildering thought, but in my view, it is scientifically accurate and completely true as well. Hmm.
即每一个小细节都很重要。因果关系无论是在过去、现在还是未来，其运作方式都是一样的。所以，如果一百万年前踩死一只虫子可以重塑世界，那么今天踩死一只虫子也能重塑世界。如果一百万年前与某人交谈可以重塑世界，那么今天与某人交谈也能重塑世界。如果五十年前与某人交谈可以重塑谁会出生，那么今天与某人交谈也能重塑五十年后谁会出生。这是一个令人困惑的想法，但在我看来，它在科学上是准确的，而且也是完全真实的。嗯。
So we've been talking about some of the ways in which humans overlook randomness and chance, but you say that modern humans have engineered an interconnected world that is even more subject to random occurrences. How so, Brian? So, the effects of randomness are produced by interconnectivity, and we have created a hyper- hyper connected world. And so one of my favorite examples of this is the thing where many of you will remember a couple years ago in 2021, this little gust of wind tips this boat sideways in the Suez Canal,
我们一直在讨论人类忽视随机性和偶然性的一些方式，但你说现代人类设计了一个互联互通的世界，这个世界更容易受到随机事件的影响。怎么说呢，布莱恩？随机性的影响是由互联性产生的，而我们创造了一个高度、高度互联的世界。我最喜欢的例子之一就是很多人可能还记得几年前，也就是2021年，苏伊士运河里的一阵小风把一艘船吹得侧翻了，
and it blocks global trade and it caused something like $50 billion of economic damage from one boat from one gust of wind, right. And the reason that was possible is because we had optimized all of our systems to the absolute limit, such that this tiny little chance event could debilitate global trade. And so, you know, we see this with the pandemic, where a single mutation of a single virus infecting the human in Wuhan shuts down the world almost instantaneously over the span of several weeks because of this hyper-connectivity.
它阻断了全球贸易，仅仅因为一艘船和一阵风，就造成了大约500亿美元的经济损失，对吧。之所以会发生这种情况，是因为我们将所有的系统都优化到了极致，以至于这种微小的偶然事件就能瘫痪全球贸易。所以，你知道，我们在大流行中也看到了这一点，由于这种高度互联性，单一病毒的单一突变感染了武汉的一个人，在几周的时间里几乎瞬间让世界陷入停滞。
So there've been pandemics in the past, but they didn't have quite so wide ranging or quite so rapid of effects. So we've engineered this world that is extremely sensitive to chance events, constantly changing in these profound and upsetting ways all of the time. And I think that's partly by design
所以，过去也曾有过大流行，但它们的影响并没有那么广泛，也没有那么迅速。因此，我们设计了一个对偶然事件极其敏感的世界，它时刻都在以这些深刻而令人不安的方式不断变化。我认为这在一定程度上是刻意为之的。
You say that also our relentless drive for efficiency Has produced very little slack in our lives and the reduced slack itself has effects on randomness and chance. How so? There's all sorts of areas in in the social world where we are told to squeeze Every ounce of inefficiency out of the system. This is true for our lives as well, right? The life hack approach is to always get that little extra 1% of efficiency into your life. And the problem is that that means that there's a cost to it, which is resilience.
你说我们对效率的不懈追求，导致我们的生活中几乎没有余地，而这种余地的减少本身也会对随机性和偶然性产生影响。怎么说呢？在社会世界的各个领域，我们都被告知要从系统中挤出每一盎司的低效率。这对我们的生活也适用，对吧？“生活黑客”的方法就是总是要在生活中多挤出那1%的效率。问题在于，这样做是有代价的，那就是韧性。
Because if you are optimized and absolutely efficient to the limit the system or your life becomes brittle It becomes one where there's no give so when something inevitably goes wrong as it always does There's no ability to absorb it and all of us sort of know this with our daily schedules, right? I mean if you pad something by 10 minutes, it's less efficient But when something goes wrong or you get stuck in traffic you end up still being on time And what we're basically doing on a social level is we're taking out that buffer It's less efficient. But when something goes wrong or you get stuck in traffic, you end up still being on time. And what we're basically doing on a social level is we're taking out that buffer.
因为如果你被优化到极致，系统或你的生活就会变得脆弱。它会变得没有弹性，所以当不可避免的事情发生时——就像它总是会发生的那样——它就没有能力去吸收冲击。我们所有人都通过日常日程安排了解这一点，对吧？我的意思是，如果你在某件事上预留了10分钟的缓冲时间，它的效率确实降低了，但当出现问题或你被堵在路上时，你最终还是能准时到达。我们从社会层面所做的，基本上就是去掉了那个缓冲。它效率较低，但当出现问题或你被堵在路上时，你最终还是能准时到达。我们从社会层面所做的，基本上就是去掉了那个缓冲。
We're saying the buffer is evil because it's inefficient, which is why when you sort of think about the last 25 years of global history, it's a series of these sort of small changes that have created cascading catastrophes. And it's why I think we all have this sense that the whole world is constantly falling apart at a quicker pace than usual.
我们说缓冲是邪恶的，因为它效率低下，这就是为什么当你思考过去25年的全球历史时，它是一系列导致连锁灾难的小变化。这就是为什么我认为我们都有这种感觉，整个世界正以比平时更快的速度不断分崩离析。
I think it is partly because it is. So you make a very interesting argument that for modern people, there's a big shift in terms of how predictable our lives are on a micro scale versus a macro scale. What do you mean by this, Brian? Yeah, so this is where I sort of put myself in the, in the sort of perspective of a hunter gatherer living 200,000 years
我认为这在一定程度上是因为事实确实如此。所以你提出了一个非常有趣的论点，即对于现代人来说，我们的生活在微观层面和宏观层面的可预测性发生了巨大的转变。你这是什么意思，布莱恩？是的，这就是我把自己置于20万年前狩猎采集者视角的地方，
ago, right? Their world was extremely unstable and unpredictable day to day, because they didn't know if a predator would eat them, they didn't know if their crop would fail, or if their gathering would fail. They didn't know if they would have their next meal or if they would die in childbirth, right? Really scary stuff happening all the time. But their overall world never really changed.
对吧？他们的世界在日常生活中极其不稳定且不可预测，因为他们不知道是否有捕食者会吃掉他们，不知道他们的作物是否会歉收，或者采集是否会失败。他们不知道自己是否能吃上下一顿饭，或者是否会死于难产，对吧？非常可怕的事情一直在发生。但他们的整体世界从未真正改变过。
So, you know, you think about generation after generation, if you know how to hunt and you know how to gather, you can teach your kids and they're gonna have the exact same strategy for life. So parents taught children how to live and it was very stable across generations. Now think about our world. We live in a world that is hyper optimized and seemingly stable day to day. Google Maps
所以，你知道，想想一代又一代，如果你知道如何狩猎和采集，你就可以教你的孩子，他们将拥有完全相同的生活策略。所以父母教孩子如何生活，这在几代人之间是非常稳定的。现在想想我们的世界。我们生活在一个高度优化、看似日常稳定的世界里。谷歌地图
tells you how long it's going to take you to get to work and usually it's pretty close. You click a button on Amazon and the package arrives at the right time or at least on the right day. You know, we have these sorts of illusions of control that exist from systems that are seemingly extremely stable on the day to day. At the same time, the overall structure of our world has radically changed. I mean, the internet didn't exist when I was a kid, at least not for most people. AI didn't exist for most people until a year or two ago. You have all these macro level changes, computerization, all this sort of stuff, you know, smartphones. And it's created this dynamic that's really unique in human history, where children teach
告诉你去上班需要多长时间，通常都很准。你在亚马逊上点击一个按钮，包裹就会在正确的时间，或者至少在正确的日子送达。你知道，我们从看似极其稳定的日常系统中获得了这种控制的错觉。与此同时，我们世界的整体结构已经发生了根本性的改变。我的意思是，我小时候互联网并不存在，至少对大多数人来说不存在。直到一两年前，人工智能对大多数人来说还不存在。你有所有这些宏观层面的变化，计算机化，所有这些东西，你知道，智能手机。它创造了一种在人类历史上非常独特的动态，即孩子教
their parents how to navigate the world rather than the reverse. So this is where I think we have engineered a system, a sort of upside down world, different from all of the humans that came before us, where, you know, the Starbucks will never change, but the rivers will dry up and our democracies might collapse. And when you think about that, it's the inversion of what we want. What we want is sort of the serendipity and unexpected joy of flukes in our daily life.
父母如何在这个世界上航行，而不是相反。所以这就是我认为我们设计了一个系统，一个某种颠倒的世界，与我们之前的所有人类都不同，在那里，你知道，星巴克永远不会改变，但河流会干涸，我们的民主制度可能会崩溃。当你想到这一点时，这正是我们想要的倒置。我们想要的是日常生活中偶然事件带来的那种机缘巧合和意想不到的快乐。
Meanwhile, we want the overall superstructure of the world to be pretty stable and reliable. And I think we've sort of inverted that. And it's something that's a great challenge for the 21st century to resolve. Our failure to recognize that our world is saturated with randomness comes with great costs. We expect order and predictability to prevail and then get blindsided by sudden crises. We see each disastrous development as an inexplicable one-off occurrence, instead of the product of a world that was always full of chance, and that has become more vulnerable to chance
与此同时，我们希望世界的整体上层建筑是相当稳定和可靠的。我认为我们已经把这一点颠倒过来了。这是21世纪需要解决的一个巨大挑战。我们未能认识到我们的世界充满了随机性，这付出了巨大的代价。我们期望秩序和可预测性占主导地位，然后被突如其来的危机打得措手不及。我们将每一次灾难性的发展都视为无法解释的孤立事件，而不是一个始终充满偶然性、且变得越来越容易受到偶然性影响的世界的产物。
in the modern age. When we come back, how we can learn to recognize the role of randomness, and how to turn these forces to our advantage. You're listening to Hidden Brain. I'm Shankar Vedanta. This is Hidden Brain. I'm Shankar Vedantaam. Brian Klaus is a political scientist at University College London. He is the author of Fluke, Chance, Chaos, and Why Everything We Do Matters. So Brian, I think when we listen to these stories of chance, some of us might find these
在现代社会。当我们回来时，我们将探讨如何学会认识随机性的作用，以及如何将这些力量转化为我们的优势。你正在收听的是《隐藏的大脑》。我是尚卡尔·韦丹塔姆。这是《隐藏的大脑》。我是尚卡尔·韦丹塔姆。布莱恩·克劳斯是伦敦大学学院的政治学家。他是《侥幸：偶然、混乱以及为什么我们所做的一切都很重要》一书的作者。所以布莱恩，我想当我们听到这些关于偶然性的故事时，我们中的一些人可能会觉得这些
stories disturbing, and in part I think we find it disturbing because it challenges the idea that we are actually in control of what's happening. You say that it's important to come to terms with the fact that such control might actually be impossible. You deal with this yourself using something that you call the snooze button effect. What is the snooze button effect? So the snooze button effect is a term I've coined, which is trying to showcase how our lives are constantly being diverted by the choices we make in our daily existence. So imagine that tomorrow you wake up and you slap the snooze button because you're a little bit tired. Now imagine that your story of
故事令人不安，我认为在某种程度上我们觉得它令人不安，因为它挑战了我们实际上能够控制正在发生的事情这一观念。你说重要的是要接受这样一个事实，即这种控制实际上可能是不可能的。你自己使用一种你称之为“贪睡按钮效应”的东西来处理这个问题。什么是贪睡按钮效应？所以贪睡按钮效应是我创造的一个术语，它试图展示我们的生活是如何不断地被我们在日常生活中所做的选择所改变的。所以想象一下，明天你醒来，因为有点累，你拍了一下贪睡按钮。现在想象一下，你的生活故事
your life rewinds by five seconds and in this version, you don't slap the snooze button, you get out of bed. Now, it is completely obvious to me that your life will unfold at least somewhat differently depending on these two versions of events because you will have different encounters that day with different people, your conversations will go differently. And the ripple effects from that will emanate out throughout your life, the little tiny changes will add up. And so when I think about the snooze button effect, it's a
倒带了五秒钟，在这个版本中，你没有拍贪睡按钮，你起床了。现在，对我来说完全显而易见的是，你的生活会根据这两个版本的事件而以某种不同的方式展开，因为那天你会与不同的人有不同的相遇，你的谈话也会有所不同。由此产生的连锁反应会贯穿你的一生，微小的变化会累积起来。所以当我想到贪睡按钮效应时，它是一个
reminder that yes, I don't have control. I don't know how the effects of that choice will play out. I find this incredibly liberating and incredibly empowering. And there's two reasons for that. One is that it's liberating because it means that with a little bit less control, I should take less credit for my success
提醒，是的，我没有控制权。我不知道那个选择的影响会如何发挥作用。我觉得这非常令人解放，也非常令人振奋。原因有二。一是它令人解放，因为它意味着在控制力稍弱的情况下，我应该少为我的成功邀功，
and less blame for my failure. The stakes are a little lower because I'm not the sole author of the story of my life. There's countless authors that are constantly writing little bits of my story. But it's also extremely uplifting and I think empowering because it means that there is no moment of our lives that is a throwaway moment. There's not a single moment of our existence
少为我的失败责怪自己。赌注稍微低了一些，因为我不是我人生故事的唯一作者。有无数的作者在不断地书写我故事的一小部分。但它也极其令人振奋，我认为它赋予了力量，因为它意味着我们生活中没有一个时刻是浪费的时刻。我们存在的每一个时刻
that doesn't matter because every single moment is producing these ripple effects. And even when we're unaware of them, they matter. So the moment that a baby is conceived, if there is any millisecond difference in that moment, a different child is born, right? Now we sort of all intuitively understand that, but if you actually think about what that means, it means that on the day of conception, if you stop to have a sip of
都很重要，因为每一个时刻都在产生这些连锁反应。即使我们没有意识到它们，它们也很重要。所以当一个婴儿受孕的那一刻，如果那一刻有任何毫秒的差异，就会诞生一个不同的孩子，对吧？现在我们都直观地理解这一点，但如果你真的思考这意味着什么，它意味着在受孕的那天，如果你停下来喝一口
coffee or if you don't, you have a different kid. But that's true for the day before, and the day before that, and the day before that. All of those things in our lives that culminate in that one moment when the baby is conceived had to be exactly as they were for that child to be born. This is the phrase that I borrow from the social scientist Scott Page where he says that we control nothing but we influence everything. Hmm. Now the fact that we have little control, I think, prompts many people to say, how can I figure out a way to exercise more control? If you think about people who go down the IVF route of conception, for example, you
咖啡，或者如果你不喝，你就会有一个不同的孩子。但这对于前一天、前一天的前一天，以及再前一天也是如此。我们生活中所有在婴儿受孕那一刻达到顶峰的事情，都必须完全按照它们本来的样子发生，那个孩子才能出生。这是我从社会科学家斯科特·佩奇那里借用的一句话，他说我们什么都控制不了，但我们影响一切。嗯。现在，我们几乎没有控制权这一事实，我认为促使许多人说，我怎样才能找到一种方法来行使更多的控制权？例如，如果你想到那些通过试管婴儿受孕的人，你
in fact have more control than if you went the natural route of conception. And there's the illusion, I suppose, with IVF that maybe you actually do have more control over an unpredictable process. So I think one of our reactions to unpredictability and chance is to say, how can we exert more control? How do we keep all these forces at bay so that in fact I can chart my own course? You think that that's a mistake? Aaron Ross Powell The way I sometimes describe this is, imagine a world of perfect control, right? Where you could pick everything that happened in your life It would be the most dystopian hellscape you could imagine if uncertainty was eliminated Imagine that you knew when you were 10 years old
实际上比走自然受孕路线有更多的控制权。我想，试管婴儿有一种错觉，认为你可能确实对一个不可预测的过程有更多的控制权。所以我认为我们对不可预测性和偶然性的反应之一是说，我们如何才能施加更多的控制？我们如何才能将所有这些力量拒之门外，以便我实际上可以规划自己的路线？你认为这是一个错误吗？阿伦·罗斯·鲍威尔我有时这样描述它：想象一个完美控制的世界，对吧？在那里你可以选择生活中发生的一切。如果消除了不确定性，那将是你所能想象的最反乌托邦的地狱。想象一下，当你10岁时，你知道
Exactly who you're going to marry Imagine if you knew the exact moment of your death, right for a lot of us It would be incredibly crippling and the moments of creativity of serendipity of joy I mean if you think about all those moments in your life that really stuck with you, how many of them were planned beforehand to a T, right? Even in the planned events that we have, like a celebration, a wedding, a birthday, whatever, often the stuff we remember the most is the unplanned flourish, you know, when the uncle did this unexpected thing on the dance floor or whatever. So we pretend that uncertainty is always bad. And sometimes it is. I mean, a cancer diagnosis is
你到底要嫁给谁。想象一下，如果你知道自己死亡的确切时刻，对吧？对我们许多人来说，这将是极其令人瘫痪的，创造力、机缘巧合、快乐的时刻……我的意思是，如果你想想你生活中所有那些真正让你印象深刻的时刻，有多少是提前计划好的？即使在我们拥有的计划好的活动中，比如庆祝活动、婚礼、生日等等，我们最常记住的往往是那些计划外的点缀，你知道，当叔叔在舞池里做了这个意想不到的动作等等。所以我们假装不确定性总是坏事。有时确实如此。我的意思是，癌症诊断是
scary and you don't know what's going to happen. And I'm not trying to say that that's a good thing, but pure certainty, pure control would cripple everything that's good about being a human. And so it's a mistake to try to stamp out all levels of uncertainty, all levels of chance, and all serendipity from our lives. One of your important insights, Brian, is that we should all focus a little less on control and a little more on resilience. What do you mean by this? Yeah, so I think there's an acknowledgement that we have less control. The question is, what do you do about it? The world is uncertain.
可怕的，你不知道会发生什么。我并不是说这是一件好事，但纯粹的确定性、纯粹的控制会削弱作为人类的所有美好之处。因此，试图从我们的生活中消除所有层面的不确定性、所有层面的偶然性和所有机缘巧合是一个错误。布莱恩，你的重要见解之一是我们都应该少关注控制，多关注韧性。你这是什么意思？是的，所以我认为我们承认我们控制得更少。问题是，你对此做了什么？世界是不确定的。
It's a scary place often. And this is where I think both our social systems and individuals themselves need to focus more on resilience. Resilience is where even if something goes wrong, even if the unexpected befalls you, you're gonna be okay. So, when you think about stuff where on a personal level, you don't have control, it's the stuff where it's all about, you know, external validation, for example,
它通常是一个可怕的地方。这就是我认为我们的社会系统和个人本身都需要更多地关注韧性的地方。韧性是指即使出了问题，即使意想不到的事情降临到你身上，你也会没事的。所以，当你想到个人层面你无法控制的事情时，就是那些完全关于，你知道，外部验证的事情，例如，
what other people do in reaction to how you behave. If you have intrinsic motivation, things like passion, things like, you know, intellectual discovery, things like exploring the world, it's not contingent on how somebody else reacts to you. It's just the thing itself and that's more resilient. So, you know, when I think about what I've done with my own life, I do spend more time with things that have intrinsic and immediate value to me like going out into nature. Like traveling with a, you know, sort of an eye for exploration, like walking my dog because I like walking my dog.
别人对你的行为有什么反应。如果你有内在动力，比如激情，比如，你知道，智力发现，比如探索世界，它就不取决于别人如何反应。它只是事物本身，这更具韧性。所以，你知道，当我想到我对自己生活所做的事情时，我确实花更多时间在对我具有内在和直接价值的事情上，比如走进大自然。比如带着一种，你知道，某种探索的眼光去旅行，比如遛我的狗，因为我喜欢遛我的狗。
And, you know, the sort of periods where I've felt worst often have been when I've put something out in the world and someone has said something horrible about it and I've put all of my eggs in the sort of external validation basket, that's where I both don't have control and I'm ceding my wellbeing to other people. Right? So I sort of think that that's one of the areas where society as a whole has not learned this lesson as well, because the
而且，你知道，我感觉最糟糕的时期往往是我把一些东西放到世界上，有人说了关于它的可怕的话，而我把所有的鸡蛋都放在了某种外部验证的篮子里，这就是我既没有控制权，又把我的幸福让给了别人的地方。对吧？所以我认为这是整个社会还没有很好地吸取这一教训的领域之一，因为
sort of hyper optimized social systems that we have where, you know, everything is about short-term payoff, you've got to hit your quarter three targets and so on. That short-termism is good for efficiency, it's bad for resilience, it's bad for anticipating shocks that might come because the world is changing rapidly and is deeply uncertain. How would you apply the same insight at the level of organizations or nations, Brian? Yeah, so one of the examples I use is a case where a Latin American country was looking at different proposals for an electrical grid. And one version of the proposal was hyper efficient and way cheaper. And it was a single national grid. The second version had these sort of decoupled nodes at the regional level. So if you had a blackout in one area, you could sort of isolate it, right? But it was way less efficient
我们拥有的那种高度优化的社会系统，你知道，一切都是关于短期回报，你必须达到第三季度的目标等等。这种短期主义对效率有好处，但对韧性不利，对预见可能到来的冲击不利，因为世界正在迅速变化，并且极其不确定。布莱恩，你会如何在组织或国家层面应用同样的见解？是的，我使用的例子之一是一个拉美国家正在研究不同的电网提案。提案的一个版本是超高效的，而且便宜得多。这是一个单一的国家电网。第二个版本在区域层面有这些某种解耦的节点。所以如果你在一个地区停电，你可以把它隔离，对吧？但它的效率要低得多，
and way more expensive. Now they went with the second option, the less efficient option, and the first blackout that happened, it paid for itself. Now, if you were analyzing that choice purely on the basis of short-term profits, short-term efficiency and so on, you would never have made that choice. But because they thought about the long-term resilience
而且要昂贵得多。现在他们选择了第二个选项，那个效率较低的选项，而发生的第一次停电就让它收回了成本。现在，如果你纯粹基于短期利润、短期效率等来分析那个选择，你永远不会做出那个选择。但因为他们考虑了系统的长期韧性，
of the system, they emphasized decoupling, they emphasized mitigating risk, they thought about the what-ifs, they ended up with a smarter strategy. And I really do worry that in a moment of extreme social change and rapid technological shifting of AI and all these things, that we are thinking short-term and not enough decision-makers are pondering the what-ifs and planning accordingly for them. Would you say that your own life has become happier or at least less stressed as a result of focusing less on control?
他们强调解耦，他们强调降低风险，他们考虑了“万一”，他们最终得到了一个更聪明的策略。我确实非常担心，在社会发生极端变化和人工智能等所有这些技术的快速转变时刻，我们正在进行短期思考，没有足够的决策者在思考“万一”，并相应地为它们做计划。你会说，由于减少了对控制的关注，你自己的生活变得更快乐，或者至少压力更小了吗？
This is a fun one to talk about because I've written books in the past. This one changed my worldview completely and I feel the happiest I have literally ever been in my life. A lot of the reason for that is just because it's a mentality shift. It's sort of this understanding first off that it is unbelievably improbable that humans exist, let alone that I exist. So I feel grateful for that.
这是一个很有趣的话题，因为我过去写过书。这一本彻底改变了我的世界观，我觉得我正处于一生中最快乐的时刻。这很大程度上是因为心态的转变。首先，这是一种理解，即人类存在，更不用说我存在，是令人难以置信地不可能的。所以我对此感到感激。
It's also that when I realized the uncertainty and the lack of control that I have over my life, I have become more of an explorer, right? I've become more of an experimenter. I try things that I wouldn't try in the past. And as a result of that, I'm sort of attuned to the serendipity that happens when something unexpected comes into my life and the joy from it. Of course, there's unexpected setbacks too, but I'm more able to roll with them because I don't have the sense that I have to have top down optimized control all the time.
这也是因为当我意识到不确定性以及我对生活缺乏控制时，我变得更像一个探索者，对吧？我变得更像一个实验者。我尝试了过去不会尝试的事情。因此，我适应了当意想不到的事情进入我的生活时发生的机缘巧合，以及由此带来的快乐。当然，也有意想不到的挫折，但我更能顺其自然，因为我没有那种必须时刻拥有自上而下的优化控制的感觉。
And I think about the times in my life where I was actually probably, you know, not saddest, but not exactly my happiest is some of the time when I was on paper, the most productive with inbox zero and I was checking off, you know, every checklist was ticked. And, you know, like it sucked the joy out of life. I was on top of my sort of to-do list, but I wasn't having a good time. And so, I think there's some of these lessons that I've incorporated where you just sort of have to think, we're all in this ride that is extremely bizarre,
我想到我生命中那些我可能，你知道，不是最悲伤，但也不是最快乐的时光，就是我纸面上效率最高的时候，收件箱为零，我勾选了，你知道，每一个清单都被勾选了。而且，你知道，这吸干了生活的乐趣。我掌控了我的待办事项清单，但我过得并不开心。所以，我认为我吸收了一些这样的教训，你只需要想，我们都在这趟极其离奇的旅程中，
contingent, swayed by randomness, swayed by luck, et cetera. And we're happy to be here, we're lucky to be here, and that every moment that I have is influencing the future in some ripple effect that I don't know how it's going to play out. There's something so magical and awe-inspiring about that, that it has just utterly transformed how I think about my life and it's made me a much happier person. So what's interesting is that a lot of people, they first encounter my ideas or the ideas
偶然的，受随机性影响，受运气影响，等等。我们很高兴来到这里，我们很幸运来到这里，我拥有的每一刻都在以某种我不知道会如何发展的连锁反应影响着未来。这其中有一些非常神奇和令人敬畏的东西，它彻底改变了我对生活的看法，并使我成为了一个快乐得多的人。所以有趣的是，很多人，他们第一次接触到我的想法或偶然性和随机性的想法，
of chance and randomness and they become nihilists, right? Nothing matters. And my argument is no, everything matters, even the tiniest stuff. And if you fixate on that idea, your life will always have meaning and always feel important. And I think that's the one of the secrets to a happy life. Happy life. Thank you for having me on the show. In our companion to this episode, available exclusively to subscribers to Hidden Brain Plus, we talk with Brian about what happens if we stop trying to make our days orderly and instead, invite chaos into our lives. If you're a subscriber, that episode is available right now. It's titled Engineering Luck. If you're not yet a subscriber to Hidden Brain Plus, this is a great time to give it a try.
他们就变成了虚无主义者，对吧？什么都不重要。而我的论点是，不，一切都很重要，即使是最微小的东西。如果你专注于这个想法，你的生活将永远有意义，永远感觉重要。我认为这是幸福生活的秘诀之一。幸福的生活。谢谢你邀请我参加节目。在我们这一集的配套节目中，仅供《隐藏的大脑Plus》订阅者使用，我们与布莱恩讨论了如果我们停止试图让我们的日子井井有条，而是邀请混乱进入我们的生活会发生什么。如果你是订阅者，那一集现在就可以收听了。它的标题是《工程运气》。如果你还不是《隐藏的大脑Plus》的订阅者，现在是尝试的好时机。
We're extending our standard seven-day trial period for listeners on Apple Podcasts. Sign up in January, and you'll get 30 free days to try it out. You can sample Hidden Brain Plus by going to apple.co slash hiddenbrain and clicking Try Free. Again, just go to apple.co slash hiddenbrain and click Try Free. Hidden Brain is produced by Hidden Brain Media. Our audio production team includes Annie Murphy-Paul, Kristen Wong, Laura Quirell, Ryan Katz, Autumn Barnes, Andrew Chadwick, and Nick Woodbury. Tara Boyle is our executive producer. I'm HIDDEN BRAIN's executive editor.
我们正在为Apple Podcasts上的听众延长标准的七天试用期。在一月份注册，你将获得30天的免费试用期。你可以通过访问apple.co/hiddenbrain并点击“免费试用”来体验《隐藏的大脑Plus》。再次强调，只需访问apple.co/hiddenbrain并点击“免费试用”。《隐藏的大脑》由《隐藏的大脑》媒体制作。我们的音频制作团队包括安妮·墨菲-保罗、克里斯汀·王、劳拉·奎雷尔、瑞安·卡茨、奥特姆·巴恩斯、安德鲁·查德威克和尼克·伍德伯里。塔拉·博伊尔是我们的执行制片人。我是《隐藏的大脑》的执行编辑。
Thanks for listening. See you soon. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
感谢收听。很快再见。这一集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子即可发表评论。